me piden que encuentre el máximo común
divisor de 16 y 8 y bueno cuando pienso
en el máximo común divisor también
podemos pensar en cuál es el factor
común más grande entre 16 y 8 o tal vez
lo podemos ver como cuál es el número
más grande que divide tanto al 16 como
al 8 y además nos dicen que otra forma
de ver esto o describirlo es el mst el
dms de entre 16 y 8 es igual y es justo
lo que queremos
ok sin embargo en esta ocasión tuve
bastante suerte porque date cuenta que
el 8 divide tanto al 8 como el 16 como
el 16 es un múltiplo de 8 entonces el
número más grande que divide tanto al 8
como el 16 pues va a ser el 8 entonces
en este caso en este primer ejercicio
creo que la respuesta es muy sencilla el
máximo común divisor entre estos dos es
8 porque es el número que divide a ambos
y además es el más grande que lo hace
entonces vamos
la respuesta y perfecto está de lujo así
que vamos a la siguiente dice cuál es el
máximo común divisor entre 40 y 45 otra
forma de ver esto es el mst de 40 y 45
es igual y es justo lo que quiero
ok pues vamos a sacar el pizarrón para
resolver este problema
cuál es el m el m se de entre 40 y 45 lo
que buscamos es el factor común más
grande entre estos dos cuál es el número
que divide estos dos más grande bueno
pues lo que se me ocurre es ver cuáles
son los factores tanto de 40 como de 45
así que pongamos dos por aquí 40 cuáles
son sus factores bueno el primero que se
me ocurre es 1 y 41 y 40 son factores de
40 pero 40 también tiene mitad la mitad
de 40 es 20 por lo tanto 20 también
divide a 40 y también lo hace
40 tiene tercera no porque la suma de
estos dígitos no es divisible entre 340
tiene 4a
sin 4 por 10 es 40 entonces 40 también
tiene 44 y aquí voy a poner 10 o perdón
perdón
voy a poner 10 40 tiene quinta también 5
por 8 40 por lo tanto también tiene
quinta y es 8 ok quién más no tiene
sexta no tiene séptima y bueno octava ya
está aquí por lo tanto estos son los
factores de 40 ahora pensemos cuáles son
los factores de 45 vamos a pensar en 45
y si nosotros recordamos los factores de
45 podemos empezar con 1 y 45 y después
ver que 45 no es número par por lo tanto
no tiene mitad después podemos ver que
45 tiene tercera veamos
45 es lo mismo que 99 tiene tercera por
lo tanto 45 tiene tercera vemos esto
45 tiene tercera y cuanto es la tercera
de 45 pues podemos tomarnos la división
45 entre 33 caben 4 una vez uno por tres
es 34 menos 31 y bajo el 5 puedo bajar
este 5 y después dice 15 cada vez cinco
veces en 35 por tres es 15 y sobran 0 ok
por lo tanto 3 y 15 también dividen al
quien más cuarta 45 no tiene cuarta
porque 40 tiene cuarta más 4 es 44
entonces no llegamos al 45 y quinta
quinta tiene 5 por 9 45 pero tanto
quinta tiene 5 y 9 y quien más tiene
sexta y 6 por 7 42 6 por 8 48 no ya me
pase ok séptima 7 por 6 42 7 por 149 me
pase otra vez y octava bueno octava no
va a tener porque esto no tiene mitad
pero
entonces aquí tenemos a todos los
factores del 45 ahora vamos a
preguntarnos por cuál es el factor más
grande entre estos dos y si te das
cuenta aquí tengo un factor que se
repite
tengo un factor que se repite es el 1 y
tengo otro factor que se repite en otro
factor que se repite que es el 5 y son
todos los factores que se repiten entre
40 y 45 y si lo que busco es el máximo
común divisor lo que estoy buscando es
el factor común más grande entre 40 y 45
que es 55 es el más grande y por lo
tanto lo voy a poner aquí el máximo
común divisor entre 40 y 45 es 5 y como
ya tenemos la respuesta pues vamos a
escribirla entonces aquí en la página de
internet vámonos para acá y estamos en
la página de khan academy y entonces
puede escribir que el máximo común
divisor es 5 y listos 12
perfecto estamos bien ok vamos al
siguiente cual es el máximo común
divisor de 9 y 6 ok esto está bastante
interesante vamos a ponerlo aquí en
nuestro pizarrón
yo lo que quiero lo que estoy buscando
es el máximo común divisor ok déjame
poner esta herramienta el máximo común
divisor o déjame borrarlo aquí lo voy a
poner por acá el máximo común divisor
entre 9 y 6 y para esto pues voy a hacer
lo mismo con el 9 con el 6 ahora si yo
busco los factores del 9 los factores
del 9 quién son bueno pues es 1 3 y 9
eso está muy fácil 1 9 y después el 9
solamente se puede dividir entre 3 y
quiénes son los factores de 6
bueno pues los factores de 6 también
está muy fácil es uno
3 y 6 ok ya tengo todos los factores de
6 entonces cuando yo busco el máximo
común divisor entre estos dos date
cuenta que el 1 es un factor común de
ambos el 3 es un factor común de ambos
pero es más grande entre 1 y 3
3 por lo tanto el máximo común divisor
de estos dos es 3 ahora también hay otra
forma de resolver este mismo problema si
yo lo que quiero saber es el máximo
común divisor entre 9 y 6 pues lo que
podemos hacer a continuación es
descomponer estos dos números en
factores primos es decir me voy a tomar
al 9 y voy a buscar su descomposición en
primos el 9 tiene tercera y la tercera
de 9 es 3 ok y después el 3 ya es un
número primo y por lo tanto estoy
diciendo que al 9 lo puedo ver como tres
por tres ok esto está muy fácil y qué es
lo que pasa con el 6 pues vamos a hablar
del 6 el 6 tiene mitad y la mitad del 6
es 3 y por lo tanto me queda aquí 3 y el
3 ya es un número primo por lo tanto el
6 lo puedo ver como dos por tres el 6 es
lo mismo que 2
3 ahora si nos fijamos en la
descomposición de primos del 9 y en la
descomposición de primos del 6 los
primos que están en común entre ambos es
el 3 el único primo que está en común
entre ambos es el 3 por lo tanto puedo
concluir que el máximo común divisor de
9 y 6 es 3
entonces si yo escribo por acá mi
respuesta es 3 y comprobando perfecto lo
logramos ahora quiero que te des cuenta
de algo muy importante
imagínate y déjame borrar todo esto que
hago un ejercicio nuevo déjame borrar
todo esto imagínate que yo quiero
encontrar el máximo común divisor entre
105 y 30 entre 105 y 30 date cuenta que
son dos números bastante grandes
entonces qué te parece si utilizamos la
descomposición en primos voy a agarrar
el 105 y lo voy a descomponer en primos
105 tiene tiene tercera te das cuenta 10
5 y 6 y por lo tanto 105 tiene tercera
entonces 105
lo voy a dividir entre 3 y me va a dar 3
cabe en 10 3 veces 3 por 39 cuando yo lo
restó me queda 1 bajó el 5 y después
dice 3 cabe 5 veces en 15 5 por 3 es 15
y me sobran 0 por lo tanto tiene tercera
y la tercera de 105 es 35 pero de 35 a
su vez tiene quinta la quinta de 35 es 7
7 por 5 35 por lo tanto ya tenemos la
descomposición en primos del 105 el 105
lo voy a poner aquí al 105 lo puedo ver
como 3 por 5 por 7 perfecto y ahora si
hablamos del 30 pues agarremos el 30 por
acá el 30 lo primero que veo es que
tiene mitad entonces la mitad de 30 es
15 eso está muy fácil ok y el 15 ok y al
15 lo podemos descomponer en factores
primos el 15 es lo mismo que 3 x
de 3 x 5 por lo tanto el 30 es lo mismo
que dos por tres por 5 2
3 x 5 si lo que quiero hacer es
encontrar el máximo común divisor entre
105 y 30 ya acabamos porque porque
solamente me tengo que fijar en cuáles
son los números primos en los factores
primos en común entre 105 y 30 que por
cierto estrés y también es 5 ambos son
factores primos entre 105 y 30 por lo
tanto puedo decir que el máximo común
divisor entre estos dos es 3 por 5 lo
cual es 15 perfecto acabo de encontrar
el divisor más grande entre 105 y 30 el
máximo número que es divisor de estos 2